welcome to the United States of stupid
members of Joe Biden's cabinet and the
media continue to embarrass themselves
the first example is the guy in charge
of making sure our kids get a quality
education secretary Miguel Cardona
botching this famous Ronald Reagan quote
listen as uh I think it was President
Reagan said we're from the government
we're here to help how you do an entire
week secretary Cardona may want to have
someone fact checked his next speech
because Reagan was railing against big
government the nine most terrifying
words in the English language are I'm
from the government and I'm here to help
oh next is Homeland Security secretary
mayorcas who keeps saying that the
border is secure that's despite
mountains of Visual Evidence showing
agents overwhelmed and now there's a
train in Mexico filled with migrants
riding on top as it heads here and
finally the media is also proving to be
a bunch of clowns so-called reporter
April Ryan using value White House
briefing time to brag about how she
talked to Stevie
Wonder I had an indepth conversation
with Stevie Wonder last night who is I
Love Stevie Wonder again for the serious
question he's very concerned about the
Black Agenda falling along the Wayside
is this President amable to meeting with
Stevie Wonder who has these concerns as
far as a meeting with the president
certainly I'm not aware of any meetings
uh with with the um Mr Wonder well our
very own stupid son of a Peter duy
just talked to enrio and glacius and
he's very concerned about the Hispanic
agenda and wants a meeting Dana yeah
well you know what a lot of people want
meetings and then she has the best
answer she's like I I don't know about
any meetings I'll but or you could say
I'll get back to you or you you kick it
to somebody else you kick it call my
deputy and find out that's the kind of
question you what about secretary
mayores I well that one really drives me
crazy because he just says it with such
a straight face right and he knows it's
I believe he knows that it's not true I
think he would like it to be true
perhaps but there are things you could
do to make it that way but when you see
every day how many people are coming
across I just read on my way here 800
people were waiting across in Arizona
last night and 400 got through it's cold
and a lot of them like morania guinea
Etc so the border is not closed on the
Reagan quote so I saw that around 4:30
yesterday and changed my one more thing
at the last minute because I said this
is unbelievable not only does he get the
quote wrong which I look I'm probably
guilty of it too I've gotten many quotes
wrong but it gets the whole essence of
Ronald Reagan wrong right that's like
the whole his whole point was limited
government and you can imagine imagine
if Betsy DeVos oh God had botched a
quote from JFK Jr not JFK excuse me the
media would never stop and yet with this
one the only place you see it is here
and in the New York Post Greg geld you
know what this is Cardona should be
working at dead spin it's the same exact
thing you just took the story and you
reversed the intent this is why
politicians send their kids to private
schools yep they look at card he's
running this thing this is terrible
remember how Republicans were always the
dumb people remember that no they
weren't the dumb people they were the
scrutinized people because we're all
human and we all make mistakes Democrats
Republicans however only one side was
scrutinized because the other side was
the favorite of the media the Dems were
like you know what the Dems were like
and we're seeing this now with wokeism
they're like the really dumb but
talented jock in high school who can
show up for class and never has to do
the work and then by the end of high
school they're even dumber than they
were when they got there that's because
no one challenged them that no one
worked out their brains that's why you
have all these stupid liberals doing
stupid stuff and that's how you got
wokeism because nobody challenged them
nobody challenged the progressive ideas
as they got worse and more Manic and
more distorted and disturbed until all
of a sudden you're living in like a
freak Show Jessica you are the queen of
the freak Show what is this
back we miss you yeah I can really feel
that your name was
invoked doesn't matter how derogatory a
way it was invoked it was invoked um
first and foremost lots of smart
liberals out there I don't think you
would say like Mark Zuckerberg or Bill
Gates or a Warren Buffett don't you
attack my generalization re Hoffman with
explicitly it's in my contract when
Gutfeld does generalizations please say
something um obviously that's a
big quote to mess up because it's
signature right I I I don't have a
poster of Ronald Reagan on my wall at
home but that's one of the things that I
know that he said and as Dana was saying
it's a foundational principle of old
republicanism R Rhino republicanism at
this point that they want limited
government um and that's why people like
Ronald Reagan so much
um on the April Ryan
front I guess that you could say oh it
was a name drop or whatever but I think
it is a very valid point to bring up
that there are concerns within prominent
members of the black community that the
Black Agenda considering that
African-American voters are the core
constituency of the party and you have
seen some slippage in terms of support
for the Biden Administration and the
Biden agenda would be an issue so I I
don't think that that's that's she could
have emailed that she could have called
she was they could have emailed all she
was trying she was name dropping look at
me I'm important she mentioned Stevie
Wonder's name five times five times in
one question come on it's a great name
though like if you're going to spend
time on the phone with somebody yeah
would you want to talk to CV Wonder of
course well there you go well I I don't
see much of a difference between the
Black Agenda and the white agenda both
want Safe Streets and low prices like C
if you wonder you don't see color yeah
no I was just saying you know I want I
really want to focus on this guy Cardona
this guy is appointed by the president
he is a secretary of education the quote
is a very famous quote okay you don't
have a picture of Ronald Reagan in your
house I mean I I I love Ronald Reagan it
doesn't really matter but the guy is so
inept he is so inept that the irony was
he Associated it with a narrative uh
that government uh is in inefficient and
he believed it okay and so what Cardone
says to all the governors who in the
audience right after he says that quote
is well we're going to follow up with
every one of you to make sure that we're
available to help you I mean he is so
out of it he doesn't even know it it's
not a misquote he doesn't understand the
fundamental principle and we already
understand that as far as the Democrats
and progressives are concerned that
education doesn't matter we've seen it
over and over again whether it was with
Rachel wilinsky and the CDC and the UFT
and Randy weart and making sure that
every metric went to close the schools
and then because of the teacher
shortages they started stat started
passing laws that they no longer needed
to have college degrees and now the
unions are pushing for removal of the
requirement we had this last week that
you not necessarily have to be
proficient in Reading Writing and math
to be a teacher I mean what does that
tell you and they were willing by the
way to pass all the kids after the
pandemic without them passing any of the
requirements to graduate from high
school they're willing to just push out
that group that tells you that they
don't care if our kids are last and to
me that's very offensive it's about the
dumbing down of America it's about
taking America down while our enemies
make sure that their kids are educated
so it's not just a misquote this is a
whole movement to destroy education of
our kids and I think what Jessica was
trying to say is that she wants
everybody in the audience to send her
pictures of Ronald Reagan so she could
decorate her house appropriately coming
up despite the world being a mess
Democrats and the media have a new
talking point sleepy Joe is saving
America from World War I hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else